hello people so we weren't actually
planning on putting this reaction up on
YouTube we're gonna see an intro once
we're done with this footage from the
phone or clearly we were just wanted to
put it up on patreon because normally to
get reactions up for for music videos
you have to you know watch it and then
pause it talk about it watch it pon talk
about and we just wanted to watch it the
whole way through and I mean if we did
jump cut - probably still get blocked
worldwide there's a link in the
description box for you to just watch
the music video reaction then you can
come back here and watch our review our
thoughts on it or you can have fun in
real-time and watch the first two
minutes of this intro and then go to the
music video reaction and then come back
my super few ever you want played
alright if you've already seen the video
you just want the review yes just just
stay here John does a music video
reactions on our patreon uncut weekly
I'd say you don't want to get called out
on the next anyway yeah no we really
like talking about this song and I'm
rarely in the music video reactions with
John so didn't want to share this one
with you guys I hate music and comedy
anyway guys I heard this I heard the
song I think I heard the whole album
when I went to the gym it's a great
[ __ ] album yeah
tension and why have you heard the song
yet yes okay once so you heard the song
we haven't seen the music video I have
feeling based off what's in the song
well we might get glimpses of in the
video yeah based off some titles to of
like that are on these notifications but
yet Eminem and I like this more than the
Kamikaze album I really like this album
alive this is the way should do I think
it takes pressure off of him to like you
know not have to like promote it and
have all this hype and anticipation
leading into it so that way when it
comes out you just judge the song it was
like oh there's its ear you know
as opposed to what's it gonna be like
what do we expect from the album all
this build-up and then he still kill
anything anytime he does as he kills it
you know and I even I heard this song
first before I heard any of these I
thought it was just a song that was
released then then I was seeing on
Twitter they released the whole album I
was like what and most of the songs are
not like this one yeah so I was
expecting oh is this like a really
somber album yeah but it's not this is a
great [ __ ] out there are some really
great songs on there are some really
great beats and Ed Sheeran's back give
you a second chance buddy yeah there's
some really awesome tunes anyway
boogie I've beaten a tail Wow is using
this platform yeah okay now it makes
more sense to me why he chose this song
first as bold it's definitely a way to
kick in the door and like grab people's
attention in a way you might not have
been expecting I didn't actually hear
with the news report and the song it
starts to play and I chose not to listen
to now because I was like it's probably
gonna be in the music video so I'll just
skip it for now not gonna lie I was a
little bit late to picking up on it was
until I was watching this was like oh
he's talking this song specifically
about the Las Vegas shooting I didn't
pick up on that for some reason
everybody mentions Vegas in the
beginning I was more pulled into an egg
when I heard it lyrically oh there's a
song he has on the recovery album called
25 to life which is a song that sounds
like a breakup song the whole way
through like the first two-thirds or
something and then you find out that
it's really about his relationship with
hip-hop and I'm with a girl and here I
was more caught up in that idea you know
it's like he's done like his songs back
in the day like the Encore song I don't
know if there's a video for that
actually really shoots the crowd at the
end or something but in this one I was
thinking about how it sounds like oh
he's getting ready to do a show cuz I
didn't watch the videos it's awesome I
can't really do a show then you find out
that oh he's not getting ready to show
he's a shooter at a show
and so more of like that mislead with it
but I feel like this music video makes
it very evident up front but not up
front but like earlier on that oh no
this is not Eminem preparing to do for a
show maybe I first trying to mislead you
into thinking that but then it puts you
into the mindset well I wondered if it
was borrowing some parallels because
there are definitely a lot of especially
that one sequence of bars where he's
talking about taking a bunch of shots
and round after round and they're a
bunch of these were choices that apply
both to guns and also drinking and so I
felt like for the first 2/3 of the song
at least you can look at that from both
perspectives because some of it did seem
personal and I'm wondering if what he's
drawing a parallel with is the kind of
loneliness and Anglet anguish and
isolation and and substance abuse and
and you know what those things might
have done to factor into an event like
this because you know as a music
festival and so you have a bunch of
artists probably in a similar position
just getting ready for the show
you know wanting you to do a good job
there aren't that many people but then
switching the perspective I need to go
back in and kind of read all the lyrics
and see how everything flows we yeah it
also reminded me of hammer head that
song by The Offspring that has a similar
structure where like for the first two
thirds you think it's about one thing
and then you find out that it's about a
school shooter at the end in the last
verse when the song like really takes a
turn and ramps oh yeah this kind of
reminded me of a rap version of that and
gets all the double entendre z' between
yeah prepping for a show and then
prepping for you know it's like the same
reason you wouldn't want to go out when
there aren't that many people as maybe
the same twisted reason or some kind of
there's a link between that and like the
guy waiting for the place to be as
populated as possible like yeah I don't
know yeah I took the it's a so it's a
heavy song and there's a lot of
interesting layers to this idea of him
choosing it it's something I like to
hear his commentary on yeah because I
don't know the specifics of the Las
Vegas shooter to me it registered a bit
as drawing general parallels between a
lot of the shooters
because there are so many there are
shootings that just fly under the radar
now and that did that occur before
before it was like it's a big event that
needs to be everyone needs to be aware
of this is important to talk about a lot
of times shootings happen now that
people what I didn't hear about that I
was in Hollywood recently he and and
across the street at the W Hotel there
was a wall of police vans and apparently
they were having it was I think it was
the gay porno works but there were two
gunmen inside and they caught one and
they were searching for the other and
that was like mind-blowing to be like
this is just happening across the street
and it seems like they have it under
control but also you know there's only
finite control you can have in a stitch
like that and also for the for the song
and because to me it didn't seem like
you I don't know if he like read up on
the actual shooter and then base the you
know how curlers like Eminem's Stan
which doesn't sound like it's based off
of an actual fan but his idea of how he
interprets the psychology of certain
kind of obsessive fans and it seemed
like this is how he sort of interprets
the psychology of the of these shooters
of course specifically using the Las
Vegas man because it's a concert and I
and I wonder too you know with that
ending moment is that something Eminem
fears happening at one of his shows yeah
because at the end when he goes out to
there's a crowd there at first this is
that when I first heard the lyrics it
sounded like this another one about him
talking about how he feels like he might
be a fading star because the people
though the the the I thought the show
would be sold out apparently it's not I
mean the music video visuals really
amplify that he's someone observing and
they keep I look at the gunman I'm
talking in terms of just lyrically and
also to do this song while it puts you
in the perspective of the shooter
I'm really glad he also topped it off
with the messages of the of the text at
the end awareness this is a real problem
and not in a way to be sympathetic first
for the shooter but also to be aware
that there are a lot of undiagnosed
untreated mental illness cases like
there's there's that I don't remember
specifically what it is but there is
that line in there something about how
he
mental illness he's not oh no out of
nowhere yeah I know like no prior
convictions you know clean right until
health bill or you know so it's like
really easy for this guy to just go get
a gun because there were no signs yes
yes exactly
what I started realizing that this is a
percent of a serum like how are people
gonna be pissed off at Eminem for doing
this just because yeah you know like
this is the first impression so I'd be
curious yeah just to go back and peel
some of the layers and compare or like
the lyrics to the video and kind of get
to see like how what gets reflected
visually and what you know maybe becomes
more clear well I don't feel like he's
trying to not Slim Shady days of
provocation yeah you know killing
[ __ ] provocation with purpose yeah
exactly I don't feel like he's just
trying to rile people up you like this
is a slim Shady's oh you know this this
feels like something that that has a
real point to it like this week it's the
others oh yeah yeah granted you know a
lot of times you're listening to a whole
album I'm not the kind of listener that
always absorbs every lyric a lot of time
looking caught up and hearing the flow
and the beat and stuff but a lot of the
songs are like super badass yeah cool I
think it's pretty awesome for him to
release this song well yeah I'm
surprised people with such an important
and it's not really part of the
conversation as much as it should be
it's something that just people who seem
to have just gotten used to is another
problem you know yeah one for as much
gun imagery as there is across the genre
you know I do think it's a bit like
Taylor Swift released a song last year
that was you know sort of an advocacy
song for LGBTQ rights which didn't go
over amazingly because you know people
were sort of questioning her comparison
of her own struggles to the struggles
with Nicki mean you know all that stuff
so like she had this similar kind of
message that didn't seem to fly over as
well and seemed like it was a little
late and this again I don't know how
people were responding but this seems
even with the controversy to be timely
and even if people do get upset over
some of the lyrical content or or the
way in which yet segues from Eminem's
perspective ostensibly at first to this
perspective of the shooter I feel like
this will grab
people in a definite way you know I feel
like there's a lot to get riled about or
to dissect and yeah just the fact that
he came back and is using his platform
to be like you know we gotta address
this
it seems I'm on the more bold side for
someone in his position to do that you
know yeah maybe even though you get that
little brief imagery of Trump on the TV
screens here it's not just another [ __ ]
Trump song Mina well on the one I liked
on the TV screens is you have the the
whole chaos you know you have the
anti-gun people you have the pro-gun
people you have news reports about
shootings you have yeah you have a Trump
you have all sorts of different facets
of the conversation which is so wide and
chaotic in that contributes to why
there's no progress right now which is
mind-blowing I remember I was listening
to the radio over the course of a month
or two and the speed with which they
were able to crack down on vape juice
vaping in general for the kids was
mind-blowing to me it's like they in in
a matter of a couple months they like
made changes they got the flavored stuff
off the shelves or whatever and the
whole purpose the whole like crux of the
argument was we've got to do it for the
kids and I'm like where's this gussto
with the gun debates isn't like cuz
children and and you know like this was
a concert so I imagine a lot of young
people were there you know it's
mind-boggling
curious to see what some of these
comments are can't murder a show
nobody's at this line hits harder the
second playthrough I mean going off of
this what is currently the top comment
my takeaway from this comment is
actually the the latter part of this
sentence listen to it a second time
through I think is actually more
powerful yeah because of like I said I
have a feeling I'm kind of repeating a
poignant music video makes it a lot
clearer up front book but just listen to
it on the a I think it was smart to
actually release this one with a video
first thought people can absorb the
message better as opposed to how do I
put it I actually there's a part of me
when I first heard it where I was more
like clever as opposed to really taking
away the point
yeah because I was like oh it's about a
shooter not about Eminem about to
perform at a concert you know what I
mean
which there is that layer here like I
pointed out oh yeah I think the second
time through when you know what the
songs really get bow you can you'll pick
up on more of the deeper aspects in the
first half of it yeah you can probably
decode a lot of the wordplay and double
entendre is more finely and and I don't
know this is my second listen but this
is the more focused of the two and yeah
I mean there's there's you know a lot of
talk about the media and what that does
to us and feels like it appeals to and
is sort of probing yeah just the
darkness that does exist within all of
us which I think helps to sell the more
personal first half of the song because
we know mmm experiences this kind of
Darkness has his substance issues and
whatnot then too you know not to say
that he's the same as this guy but you
know this person has clearly had some
kind of void or darkness too and we all
live in the same society with the same
[ __ ] flying at us all the time well
that's the whole point of the mental
health portions of this people really
need help to be encouraging about that
it's like yeah this is this is
multi-layered I think and really do
respect it I appreciate that the ads the
song I think that you that a lot of
people have a lot of opinions about and
will be a conversation piece and I think
that's a good thing you know and and it
like again even if there are arguments
against like the the tastefulness of the
song or not I feel like that still
serves to kind of get a conversation
going and that's a decent use of
controversy you know it's better than
him replying and Nick Cannon yeah not
was waiting for the Nick Cannon diss at
all YouTube destroyed Nick Cannon have
you seen dislikes on those videos I
don't assume there's a white paper
dislikes huh
you know like why go after a minute
especially for Nick Cannon come on man
well yeah you know like MGK just did it
and and you know he's some more
established rap presence at the moment
than Nick Cannon is Nick Cannon doesn't
have a presence but you see I mean Nick
Cannon is a hard worker but when you
compare the yeah the rap image going up
against Eminem lethal disser and then
you got naked and star of drumline I was
bound to write host of America's come on
Nickelodeon it was he on Nickelodeon
doors is his name they can yeah I mean
he's been around since he was like a
young teenager if he likes them maybe he
may have been on the mick
well guys what you think of this song
more music video reactions to come my
rare appearance on Jon's music video
reactions that's right thanks for coming
by Greg I appreciate you you're welcome
John yeah Eminem I gotta be here anytime
there's an Eminem joint out with that
darkness
I think there is a venom reference on
the new album and one dose yes it's been
a lot of references oh good yes did you
know did the usual yeah talk about
pooping at one point it has to right
toilets oh yeah I gotta get your [ __ ]
joke in there and euthanasia like well I
mean that was Rufus that song dropped
the world like that what's the beginning
lyric of this though the walls are
closing in or something like yeah and
they dropped the world by what they want
I did a little Wayne its roof was caving
in teen halls are closing in repeating
your [ __ ] I know you made like 800 songs
you're going to have some good saps
I don't know similar did you rhyme you
in true again and to fire and desire fly
and touch the sky those are two rhyme
schemes I feel like you need to fill out
an application for now before you use
but seriously guys listen to the album
so that's great if you're an Eminem fan
I think you'll be satisfied I I did I
really did
love that album